pets love us unconditionally don't judge
us being up here and having a place for
the dogs makes all the difference in the
world I know you're happy
I'm glad dog Mountain in the dog Chapel
is an open dog park where dogs can
really connect with nature and enjoy
spending time outdoors with their with
their owners and having a place like the
dog chapel really helps people say
goodbye or also just leave a little
message about how much they loved them
it was basically started by artist
Steven eunuch he said the worst thing
he'd ever heard is it's just a dog
that's why Stephen built the dog Chapel
to memorialize these wonderful creatures
that have touched our lives so much
we've got people that pilgrimage from
every state and every continent just to
bask in the walls of the chapel and
leave a little message behind they take
comfort in knowing that those pictures
and those messages will be here for
years to come
I think dogs can bring out the best of
us and yeah it's it's horrific to say
goodbye but that's true of so many
losses in our lives there are some
places of reverence up here I think for
a lot of people however they choose to
recognize that dogs are really special
and it's one of a kind place that we
have here that allows dogs to really
shine and be cherished as the wonderful
little creatures that they are